The specifics, such as the computational power,
the memory capacity, and the number and
types of input, output of devices, may vary from one manifestation of a computer
system, to the next. For example, commensurate
with it's intended use, a cell phone
or a pda may have very limited
input/output capabilities such as a graphics display,
speakers and microphones. But on the other hand, a high end supercomputer
used for running large scale scientific applications may employ thousands
of CPUs, incorporate several terabytes of memory and be connected
an array of disks with storage capacities on the order of several parabytes.